hi i'm coulson machine gun kelly and i'm
here to do the puppy i'm allergic to
dogs
[Music]
these are adoptable puppies and i
want to adopt all of them so i'm
probably going to do half this interview
with my eyes closed i'm a very emotional
person and i don't want to get too
attached because then i'll cry on the
plane oh please don't be cute please
don't be cute are they little puppies
please don't be little puppies
oh my god it's so cute oh my god oh no
i'm already attached
[Music]
hi guys
uh i'm a big people watcher i'll
probably just
go sit and people watch it's just hard
to do that now because if i'm people
watching
they're also watching me so it just
looks like i'm staring at them weirdly
not that i guess it's any better if i'm
staring at them if i'm not i don't know
i really don't know i don't know what i
would do guys look it's it's spongebob's
house
hi
hi oh god
being able to legally drink
i'm only 11 actually
so
can't wait for that
[Music]
[Applause]
emo cactus
the one that i just wore at the
billboard awards what do you think
about these do you like these
me and my friend ma just went in our
contact list and
my phone and just
started calling people
and we're like hey
would you like to be in our movie and
then we're just like great it shoots
tomorrow so
i hope you have nothing else going on in
life right now everyone did us a favor
and showed up it was really cool
i have you guys are nasty
and that's all right
i just got one last week that's well i
got six in one in one sitting but it was
uh can i show them this real quick i'm
sorry but you can just stay right here
still i have this i got a calculator
with with a billion on it
billion dollars billion streams billion
puppies i don't know a billion is just a
good number so or i like this one i got
this the same day too
i have all these like black furry things
this isn't my actual like leg hair this
is just like
things from my pants
i have a insane with the n
crossed off so
i'm perfectly normal guys
i mean obviously
we were first-time directors so the
whole time we were just convincing the
studio who was giving us the money like
no we're totally professional we have it
all under control it's a stoner movie so
i was like really
adamant about
us having an epic smoke scene so i made
it two full days so that we could
one smoke real weed and knowing that i
didn't want to like be just so high one
day so we spread the whole smoking
section into two days and on the second
day we forgot to turn one of the
sprinklers off in the house and we set
the fire alarm off and
the sprinkler was right over the camera
and all the equipment so we like spread
like the whole the house like flooded
and we got water all over very expensive
cameras but we had it under control
totally fine super super professional
and chill
my fans
est
they hold it down for me
twin flame it's a love letter and it's
also a tragedy the dichotomy of it is
it's like a roller coaster you know
[Music]
oh yeah
what did you eat for breakfast man
you know what i'm proud of you for
feeling comfortable enough to express
yourself
should we take a poop scoop break
oh so is that p
it is i think i was rolling around in it
well that's cool that you noticed that
in the first place you're the first
person that
picked up on that i don't know i think
at the time
and most times i tend to look at things
without kind of like a
not pessimistic perspective but just
like a sad perspective like sometimes it
just feels like even in life
you're born and then you die
granted i want to look at things and be
like oh well this is your soul moving on
to the next journey and all that but
it's still kind of just sad you know i
mean so sometimes things don't always
have happy endings
god damn that's a lot of poop that's
that's almost the size of you buddy now
this is really a like don't move zone
realizing that that was p that i was
rolling around in and then now realizing
that there's
oh oh
oh it's a go
did i break the record of
onset great honored got to be known for
something
totally
my my cat's actually at the at the cat's
home right now can i see my phone
there's a camera that's in his room that
i can check on what he's doing oh don't
throw it in the okay
let's see what whiskey's doing right now
guys do you want to see my cat
do you want to see my cat
or do you just want to poop my cat's
sleeping in the balcony so apparently he
doesn't give a [ __ ] what i'm doing
oh she's awesome she would walk in the
makeup trailer every day and just
compliment everybody and then she would
sing and then she would go on set and
improv we got so much more than we
hired her for
thank you dove
definitely patrick from spongebob he for
sure is the stoniest cartoon character
brad pitt and true romance the lobster
from little mermaid sebastian that dude
was high
for sure he was high as
all these bad situations happening and
he was just like no
i was like
yeah he's high yeah and then my uncle
snoop but i've smoked a snoop which is
great you know if i could smoke with
snoop everyday i would all these
beautiful puppies are available for
adoption at north shore animal league
america thank you guys for watching this
interview
i'm sure oh
oh my god
um
cruella de vil and these are my 101
dalmatians and uh
my new movie good morning is out now
and
i hope to see you guys this summer on
the mainstream sellout tour
[Music]
you